[Applause]
welcome to swipe we've got an eclectic
mix for you this week here's what's
coming up over the next 10 minutes
testing times for Angela as she faces
the job interview of the future I get a
look at a magic table for people living
with dementia and cam is setting up the
first human colony on Mars in our games
of the year
that's also gone but we'll begin by
getting a quick look at some of the tech
stories that made headlines this week
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg turned
down a request from the British
government to give evidence to ministers
investigating the alleged abuse of user
data
he offered to send an executive in his
place instead the chair of the
parliamentary committee described it as
absolutely astonishing meanwhile the
Cambridge analytical whistleblower
Christopher Wylie gave evidence
suggesting Facebook data had a huge
impact on the outcome of the 2016
referendum on Britain's membership of
the EU a giant vending machine for cars
has opened in China the super test drive
center in Guangzhou offers motorists a
three-day test drive with cars they
select using a mobile app bookings are
confirmed with a selfie the vending
machine which holds a hundred cars is
the result of a partnership between
retail giant Alibaba and Ford driverless
mini buses are being used to help
transport people around a Berlin
hospital the German government has
pointed out they're doing things very
differently to uber the country's
Environment Minister acknowledged ubers
recent fatal accident but said they're
carrying out testing in very gradual
steps with completely different velocity
the buses will have a staff member on
board until completely driverless trials
later on and TalkTalk is facing renewed
calls to improve its security after a
hacker contacted Sky News about a floor
in its web system that went unfixed for
years the hacker found a way to
potentially trick customers into
thinking they were accessing the real
TalkTalk website the companies fixed it
and says there's no evidence to suggest
that any customers were affected
TalkTalk was previously given a record
fine after a major breach in 2015 next
up this week angela has been mingling
with business innovators to get a look
at our technology will impact our future
workplace including how we might get
hired for new jobs I'm about to take a
mixed reality assessment test which
could be how you're interviewed for jobs
in the future
startup act of you is behind the
technology which they say can be used by
employers to scan applicants and predict
their suitability for a new role wearing
a VR headset candidates are instructed
in a simulated environment like this to
carry out a series of tasks data is then
collected based on the decisions made
basically talk if you talk in the
specific experience
analyzed it to mr. Ludwig algorithms and
we can get to understand what are the
characteristics but as we can see
[Music]
very fun vault is another startup
getting attention
it gives employees the opportunity to
report any incidents of harassment at
work using blockchain technology it is
to create a safe and encrypted digital
space to report something anonymously
and you start by creating a repository
you can choose between whether it was a
bullying discrimination or sexual
harassment it's a very harder the user
experience is this notion of matching
logic so once you enter your perpetrator
name the system can then let you know
whether you are part of a wider pattern
as well as blockchain and virtual
assessment technologies there's also a
lot of hype around the use of automation
in the recruitment process via chapel
but where two companies draw the line
when it comes to minimizing human
interaction robo recruiter is one of the
firm's showcasing automated messaging it
says computer program responses are
being taken further because it saves
employers time on the more repetitive
and mundane tasks if you're looking to
hire someone one of the big things you
probably going to be asking them are
those pass questions so you use the chat
bot to be able to prequalify the person
which allows you to have a much more
meaningful conversation we spoke to one
of the masterminds behind an
organization that helped change the
world of online communications for his
view on the technologies disrupting job
functions for me it's not just about the
technology you hear a lot about the AI
where you're about blockchain it's me
it's more for me about how do we solve
the problem of actually working better
together and how can we enable
technology to help ourselves create
better or more innovative products by
using technology both by getting people
on board but also enhancing the working
relationship and there I see technology
mixing you know the art and science
becoming even more vibrant as employers
look at those faster and cheaper ways of
working automation dominates the agenda
but the challenge for employers is to
strike a balance between technological
advancement and maintaining human heart
and personality
of their company Angela bonds Sky News
now if you've ever had a family member
or friend living with dementia you'll
know how precious happy moments are and
it's that enjoyment that's behind the
development of a unique game created in
the Netherlands that's begun to arrive
in UK dementia care homes these children
might be dominating this game but it was
made for the older players around the
table they have dementia the light
projected game system is called the
Tovar Tafel that's Dutch for magic table
infrared sensors detect hand and arm
movements so when players touch the
animations the images move and react the
games are designed to create moments of
happiness and combat apathy by helping
those who have a go to be sociable
mentally stimulated and physically
active three key areas for people living
with dementia it was developed in the
Netherlands and now John here is helping
roll us out in the UK an island to as
many care homes community centers and
libraries as possible he gave up his job
as a lawyer to focus on the project
John's dad was diagnosed with dementia
when he was a child I saw a great man he
was a consultant in London become
someone that didn't recognize me wasn't
able to have any sort of relationship
with me so when I saw a piece of
technology was proving and researched to
create that relationship and that
interaction I just knew I had to get
involved
[Music]
schoolchildren visit this care home
regularly it ensures the technology
keeps being used and John says helps
bring communities together the cost of
the Tobit Apple starts at six thousand
pounds and some care homes will struggle
to afford one but staff here seem
convinced of a positive impact on
residents with dementia obviously for
someone living with dementia one of the
risks for us is they tend to withdraw
and withdraw into themselves so anything
that can actually bring them out to
share an experience to spend more time
with others and actually to exhibit some
physical behavior and activities so it's
really nice to be able to see them move
engage smile and enjoy the experience
there's another version of the Tobit
Apple made for people with learning
disabilities that's already out in the
Netherlands and I'm told there'll be a
new set of games specifically designed
for children with autism due for release
at the beginning of next year so far
this relatively simple technology seems
to be creating a lot of smiles a
different kind of gaming now his cam
with his review of some of the latest
video game releases
surviving Mars is a brand-new game for
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC and the
game is all about establishing that
first human colony on the Red Planet
surviving Mars begins with you actually
before all the humans arrive you know
you need to set up the infrastructure
for their arrival so that might be in
placing solar panels for power or wind
turbines and also creating devices that
can harvest rock from the Martian
surface to make concrete for your
buildings and that's one of the things
this game does best is it really
straddles that line between scientific
accuracy and also fun like it never lets
that stuff get in the way of what is a
good game my only criticism would be
that in the beginning there's not a lot
of tutorial to really guide you in the
right direction so your first few bases
will probably be a complete disaster but
that's okay just try try again
[Music]
north guard is a brand new real-time
strategy game that sets you in control
of a group of Vikings now it's very
reminiscent of can early civilization
games combined with a bed of early
Warcraft and also Age of Empires but
don't let that kind of nostalgic
backdrop to the game pick you off
because if there's a lot of new things
and is really enjoyable I think perhaps
the best thing about north guard is that
it puts you in charge of a group of
Vikings and as a result you know you're
building your little troop into a fully
functioning society now yes there are a
lot of challenges in north guard there
are other Viking tribes to contend with
there are even wolves and other wildlife
that will attack you without warning but
the biggest fool you have to deal with
is winter so you need to be thinking all
the way through North guard do I have
enough to supplies of food for winter do
I have enough wood for firewood
otherwise when that season rolls around
you're probably gonna die but it's a
great game definitely worth checking out
and that's why
Burnette paradise remastered is one of
those games that when I saw it was being
remastered I was just really really
excited because you see a lot of
remasters and sometimes you're thinking
is this worth it
barnett paradise remastered is
definitely one of those if you've never
played burnout before what burnout
paradise does is it puts you in a fast
car in the middle of a city that is just
a playground for you to drive around and
to smash into and while this may seem a
bit daunting at first you know often if
a game is open-world you can be spot for
choices what burnout paradise does so
well is presents you with this open
world that lets you discover what the
opportunities are so you can drive all
around this this huge city which has a
very diverse selection of locations what
I like about the way this remastered has
been done is the emphasis has been on
keeping that smooth 60 frames per second
frame rate so the game the game feels
fast you really get that sensation of
speed which is so important so it was a
lot in here and if you've never played
burnout paradise then you should
definitely check out the remaster
Assassin's Creed rogue is kind of the
Assassin's Creed game that missed a lot
of people and arrived that awkward
moment when we were jumping from the era
of the Xbox 360 and the PlayStation 3 to
the Xbox one and the ps4 so actually a
whole lot of people never played this
game which is why ruby soft have
remastered in its that usual combination
when it comes to the gameplay of
exploration and assassination combined
with some really great sailing and
piracy elements which is a lot of fun
however where I think this game suffers
this remaster suffers is is from the
success of the most recent Assassin's
Creed game origins which is fantastic
and actually altered a whole load of
elements from the game subtly and as a
result I think rogue even in its
remastered form disc kind of show its
age it still looks great and it plays
very well in the PlayStation 4 so if
you're a really huge fan of the series
then I definitely would recommend
checking out rogue but if not and you
want to play a new Assassin's Creed game
maybe check out origins as a fantastic
well that's it for this week's show
don't forget to join us for more swype
next week and in the meantime why not
follow us on Twitter then you can see
what we get up to throughout the week at
sky news white bye bye
you
[Applause]
[Music]